[Music]
thank you I'm so nervous I'm having
heart palpitations scary these no now
when you're talking to old uncle cozy
that just made it a lot scarier uncle
cozies coming around the block no no
we're just a bunch of goofballs here you
look beautiful I always forget how tall
you are
well you know what what it's just that
most people in this town are very tiny
hey you notice that everyone's much
smaller than you'd think and you are I
thought you were tall and then you're
much taller even than I thought I'm also
ranked some fabulously high heels no
let's take a look mmm okay yeah all the
actors are so short yes they're teeny
tiny people yeah when I first got out
here I would go to an audition and at
the end they would ask how tall are you
and I always knew that meant the job was
not going my way right because you can't
look too tall come yeah - and it's these
leading men that we've all grown up
thinking really punchy
they're less they're little leprechauns
you see them in person and they're like
hey Hardy Oh foolish I apologize don't
what's up I've been seeing I've been
thinking about you a lot lately because
this ad is everywhere don't trust the B
in apartment 23 ads are everywhere and
it's quite an eye-catching ad let's take
a look at this there you are in what
appears to be a shaving cream bikini
yeah okay you know I'll do anything for
a laugh I wasn't laughing
you know there that I wasn't I don't
think laughter is the reaction right
yeah do anything and they asked me if I
would consider being you know fake naked
for the billboard and I said of course
sure but I didn't think about the
results and you know the fact that now
other people will see that right
did your what about your your family did
you get calls from your do how does your
family react is obviously you know
you're you're quite famous now and and
they see an ad like that or they hear
about stuff and they you're pretty
supportive my mom buys all my magazines
however I did get a concerned voicemail
from her I woke up when I checked my
phone and she had called it 6:30 in the
morning and you always assume something
bad happens right here mom calls you
6:30 and she's like um Kristen don't
know how to say this but Ron's hunting
buddies are saying that you're in
Playboy next month I don't want to have
to buy that magazine so I called her
back and I was like listen I'm not naked
I did the 20 questions as totally classy
like you just my interview yeah yeah
yeah pose for anything no I didn't take
off my clothes
sorry right whole crowd not mine that
one no but I've done the 20 questions
yeah it's weird cuz people say like I
hear you're in Playboy this month
I'm on a haystack hey kid I did do that